so
i get a lot of questions about
the new year's
and
what i think about it and
[Music]
what are my new year's resolutions and
all that stuff
and
i'm actually not the best at that kind
of thing
any of that kind of thing i'm not great
at i'm not great at birthdays or
anniversaries
or
holidays really because
for me and i i think this is actually a
fault for me these are just
just another day
that's
the way i think about them is it's just
another day
and i don't do anything special on these
days
because
well because i think every day is
special like every day is a gift
every day
that being said i do understand the idea
and i do
think it is good
to
pause and take a breath
and do
assessments
and acknowledge what i've done right
what i've done wrong
where i've succeeded where i've failed
what we can celebrate and
what we can learn
what corrective measures we can take
so
let's look at the new year
what is the new year's resolution
my wife used to ask me that question
when we were younger
before she really knew me
she'd say what's your new year's
resolution going to be darling
and i used to say the same thing every
year i'd say my new year's resolution is
i'm going to surf more and get better at
jiu jitsu
and it was funny because i was always
trying to do that anyway
every day
i was trying to surf more and get better
at jiu jitsu
so a new year's resolution wasn't going
to change my habits
and to this day i'm still trying to surf
more and get better at jiu jitsu and i
think i always will be doing those
things so
what do i think would be a good
new year's resolution
when i
do an assessment and look at my life
i think i have
benefited the most from one thing
that i do
and that is
think
strategic
now this is uh this is a military term
strategic in the military means
big picture it means long term
strategic in military terms is where you
are going to end up
that's thinking strategic and the
opposite
is tactical thinking
tactical thinking which again in the
military means
[Music]
short-term thinking it means
it means immediate action it means
what's happening right now
so
so there's a big difference this is the
differentiator
for me is thinking long term versus
thinking short term
and
i believe that
this thinking long term this
thinking strategic is one of the most if
not the most
important concepts
a person
can consider
in order to improve themselves and
improve their lives so so
here's some examples short-term thinking
short-term thinking says
the donut tastes good eat it
short-term thinking says
one workout doesn't matter
i can skip it
short term
tactical thinking
is the part of your brain
that says
i should just finance this
this new car or this new watch or this
new tv or whatever else instead of
actually saving and paying cash for
something that you can actually afford
short short term thinking encourages you
to make
short-term emotional decisions that hurt
you in the long run
and they definitely don't move you
toward your overall strategic goals
the more
short-term decisions you make
decisions that are based on that
immediate gratification
decisions
based on quick emotional satisfaction
and even based on involuntary chemical
releases in your body that dopamine hit
the further from the path you will stray
so
what i'm saying is don't do that
instead
think strategic think long term act
strategic
take action that improves your long-term
position
and moves you toward your long-term
goals how do you do that
first figure out where you want to go
figure out who you want to be figure out
what you are trying to do with your life
write them down
what do you
what are you saving for
what are you working toward
what kind of physical condition do you
want to be in what kind of relationships
do you want to have
what skills are you trying to develop
and
just like any leader
you have to explain to yourself
the why
why do you want to save money
why do you want to be in that physical
condition why do you want those
relationships or why do you want those
skills
you are
your own leader give yourself the
mission and explain the why behind those
goals
write those things down in simple clear
concise language
read it before you go to bed read it
when you wake up read it every day until
it is embedded in your brain
consciously and subconsciously
and
once you've written those things down
now with
all this talk about strategic thinking
also know this
you need
tactical wins
you need to win battles in order to win
the war you need to get out of bed you
need to run you need to work out you
need to read and study and practice and
you need to do things that you don't
necessarily want to do
and i know that can be hard that's why
people lose the war
that's why people never achieve their
strategic goals they lose the little
tactical battles the death of a thousand
cuts
one missed workout at a time
one
donut bypasses security
and then another
and then another and it all adds up why
because we don't think about the big
picture
we don't see
the decay
from altitude we don't see it from an
elevated position we are like the frog
boiling in the pot
as the temperature slowly increases
one degree at a time
one degree at a time one degree closer
to death one degree closer
to failure
that is why
to win tactically we have to think
strategic all the time
think strategic all the time now that
you know what you're trying to achieve
ask yourself this question
ask yourself this question before any
action or any inaction
ask yourself this question
what i am doing
what i am about to do
is it going to help me get where i am
going is this action going to make me
stronger or weaker
is this action going to make me smarter
or more skilled will this action
move me toward the strategic long-term
goals i am trying to achieve in my life
and do not lie to yourself
don't
don't don't rationalize don't negotiate
you
you have to tell yourself the truth
that is where discipline comes from
discipline is rooted in the truth we
tell ourselves and discipline delivers
long-term strategic success
am i a am i a disciplined person sure
but that discipline is there because i
know and understand my long-term goals
and i know why those goals are important
i think strategic
strategic thought
is discipline thought strategic thought
allows you to make the right tactical
actions to move you forward to achieve
your goals
to be
who you want to be and do what you want
to do
so
for
2022 and for life
think strategic
know
why you are doing what you are doing
and then get out there every day
and win those
small
tactical short-term battles
so you can win the strategic long-term
victory
that puts you where you want to be and
it's not going to be easy
the fight the daily fight is a challenge
you will not always
want to do what you need to do
you will not always feel like doing
something you need to do
you may not want to fight that battle
but you need to
you need to you need to know your
strategic goals and you need to know why
they are important and then you need to
get up
get out of your damn bed get off your
phone
get out of the soft and addictive
comfort zone
that weakens you
and destroys your goals
and you need to go out there into the
world
and get after it
have a good
2022
and i will see you
on the path